[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission au décrypteront comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 1er février
des restaurants qui rouvre en france
après un appel à la désobéissance civile
lancé il ya plusieurs semaines
une manière pour eux d'exprimer leur
ras-le-bol après trois mois de fermeture
dès ce matin bruno le maire a prévenu
ceux qui enfreignent les règles verront
leur accès au fonds de solidarité
suspendu pendant un mois et
définitivement en cas de récidive
il n'y a pas qu'en france partout en
europe les gouvernements s'inquiètent de
l'adhésion de la population restrictions
qui dure depuis maintenant presque un an
certains pays limitent la circulation de
leurs habitants d'autres font le choix
de ne pas les confiner après des pays
bas et le danemark s'étant l'autriche
que des manifestants étaient mobilisés
hier
[Musique]
coup d'état en birmanie l'armée a pris
le pouvoir la dirigeante du pays en
sushi a été arrêté son parti était sorti
victorieux des élections de novembre à
scrutin remis en cause par les
militaires ils ont proclamé l'état
d'urgence pour un an londres convoque
l'ambassadeur de birmanie
[Musique]
braver l'interdît et ouvrir coûte que
coûte leur établissement un appel à la
désobéissance a été lancée il ya
plusieurs semaines par des restaurateurs
pour ce lundi 1er février à midi un
signe de protestation contre la
fermeture qui leur est imposée depuis le
28 octobre
si en province de nombreux restaurateurs
ont pu le faire à part ils se sont
montrés bien plus discret des chats des
attaques
on est en plein coeur de paris les
restaurants sont soit fermées soit
réalise de la vente à emporter l'appel à
la désobéissance civile et à l'accueil
des clients en salle n'a pas vraiment
été entendu et peut-être que la dernière
sortie issus du ministre de l'économie y
est pour quelque chose
les restaurateurs qui ouvre ne
bénéficieront plus du fonds de
solidarité pendant un mois
et s'il ya récidive ils le perdront tout
court et ce fonds de solidarité il faut
savoir qu'il s'élève à dix mille euros
par mois ou une indemnisation de 20% du
chiffre d'affaires de 2019
dans la limite de 200 mille euros par
mois forcément cette annonce de bercy
elle a donc quelque peu douché les
espoirs de rue bellion de certains
restaurateurs mais pour d'autres il est
imprudent et irresponsable d'aller
contre l'interdiction acté pour lutter
contre le coc vie de 19
c'est le cas de valérie gérante de son
restaurant
et parce que l'envi lui manquait elle a
mis le couvert et service des clients
atypique vous avez pu croire aux gens
que vous allez vous allez ouvrir
aujourd'hui parce qu'entre les coups de
filet
clients sur place vous avez dû vous
voyez ça j'ai pas fait croire j'ai juste
repro fit et du petit écran de lumière
qu'on me donnait pour pouvoir faire
passer mon message c'est à dire juste
remettre un petit peu de vie dans mon
restaurant sans faire prendre de danger
à personne voilà redresser des tables et
voilà m m juste en scène une vingtaine
de restaurants où on reste positif
moi je sais que j'essaye de travailler
un petit peu
avec ma clientèle qui est génial et qui
a ses fidèles donc je fais un peu de
vente à emporter à son
en main basée sur notre chiffre
d'affaires donc c'est beaucoup plus
réaliste c'est juste pour mais vous
comprenez que les gens soient impatients
de revenir manger au restaurant
bien sûr bien sûr que je le comprends
moi même je suis impatiente comme eux et
bien évidemment c'est dans notre adn
d'aller au restaurant et dans les bars
enfin vie on est français on aime manger
on aime boire
donc effectivement je comprends
totalement que ça manque aux gens ça me
manque terriblement terriblement je rêve
d'aller boire un café je sais ce que je
fais tous les matins normalement je vais
boire un café en terrasse
là ça me manquerait beaucoup situation
intenable également pour eliès gérant
d'un kebab dans le 18e arrondissement
son établissement a perdu 70% de son
chiffre d'affaires depuis la fermeture
des restaurants
il y a plus de trois mois ces retours
avec le coverflow à 18 heures là je vois
me dis-je pharma 18 et or à partir du
18h confort commencé à travailler
normalement n'ont aucun partir de 18h
les gens ils sortent de leur travail
pour leur prendre leur sandwich et
ranches mais comme ça c'est dur c'est
vraiment dur des clients à la table d'un
restaurant c'est presque devenu de la
science fiction en cette période de
pandémie
des établissements qui pourrait pourtant
ne pas rouvrir de sitôt pas avant le 6
avril en croire nos confrères du point
et en cette journée d'appel à la
désobéissance civile stéphane turillon
le chef de la source bleue accusant dans
le doubs avait promis qu'il rouvrirait
son restaurant aujourd'hui en dépit de
la menace de sanctions mais face aux
gendarmes et aux risques encourus
l'artisan finalement reculé tout en
offrant des plats à emporter ou clients
pour en parler nous sommes avec randall
schwerdorffer l'avocat du restaurateur
c'est notre rubrique l'invité
bonsoir en dalles je perde warfare merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
votre client qui a donc renoncé à cette
désobéissance civile finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il en a dissuadé alors
écoutez d'abord il ya eu les annonces ce
matin effectivement une semaine on vous
annonce était extrêmement qu'elle
annonce qui consiste en une menace toute
assez univoque c'est à dire que s'ils
ont bravé l'interdît et bien à l'écouté
des sanctions étaient financières
étaient manifestement immédiate
le chef du rayon est déjà une situation
financière extrêmement compliqué c'était
très difficile d'en rajouter
et effectivement lorsque nous nous
sommes retrouvés sur place on a trouvé
un accord pour mettre en place un
protocole pour servir les plats du
restaurant mais dans des conditions
respectueuses du protocole sanitaire
actuelle donc cela veut dire que cet
appel à la désobéissance civile de
certains restent au rouge a réduit d'une
certaine manière c'est tombé à l'eau
parce que bruno le maire a menacé de ne
plus payer ces aides
c'est bien ça mais vous savez respecter
restaurant se seront arrêtées
ça doit bientôt cesser et plus de trois
mois les restaurateurs beaucoup de
restaurateurs ont de grosses difficultés
financières si vous voulez et donc
effectivement si en plus de ces
difficultés financières et ils ont
besoin de rouvrir travailler pour gagner
de l'argent pour payer ce qu'ils doivent
payer et c'est vrai que les aides
aujourd'hui ne permet déjà de ne
permettent pas de faire ça si vous
voulez à tous les impératifs
si en plus on se rajoutent des sanctions
pécuniaires très significative à partir
de ce moment là pour le chef du rayon
c'est le dépôt de bilan
c'est le dépôt de bilan avec les
licenciements qui vont avec cd pas non
plus ce qui est souhaité à ce qui est
souhaitable et ce qu'on cherchait avant
tout ce que cherchait le chef du rayon
dans son action c'est surtout de créer
un dialogue constructif pour évoluer par
rapport aux réalités actuelles
concernant les restaurants
alors c'est important de le dire a
souligné cet objectif à ce qu'il a eu
gain de cause finalement ce chef et des
autres restaurateurs évidemment à
travers lui parce que y at il vraiment
un dialogue puisque bruno le maire a
répondu par pas le chantage on peut
appeler ça comme on veut mais voilà vous
ne respectez pas la loi je vous coupe
certaine manière donc ça peut être n'y a
pas de dialogue
n'ont ils pas d'éloges pour l'instant ce
sont les menaces étaient c'est choquant
d'ailleurs que un ministre s'exprime de
cette façon là on ne descend directement
des gens qui ne sont pas des voyous qui
sont des travailleurs qui veulent juste
se travaille et qui ont des impératifs
financiers importants et c'est d'y aller
lyon c'est très mal vécu ce kit de deux
places derrière tous ces chefs il ya des
familles il ya des engagements
financiers on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi si vous voulez la
désobéissance civile à laquelle on a
appelé ses pour entrer dans une fête rue
discussions avec l'exécutif mais surtout
parce qu'on aimerait d'abord que nos
politiques locaux et malheureusement que
déploré qu'on n'ait pas eu de députés
présents pour représenter et porter la
parole le d'amande ces restaurateurs à
paris on souhaiterait vraiment que les
décisions sur les ouvertures de
restaurants soient gérées plus tôt par
les municipalités au cas par cas en
fonction de chaque restaurant et ce
serait beaucoup plus réaliste beaucoup
plus respectueux aussi désolé les autres
et des destins terré que ce soit
l'intérêt finances économie d'où
l'intérêt de sanitaires par des gens qui
sont sur le terrain qu'ils connaissent
le restaurant vous prenez le cas du chef
du rayon la vente à emporter il ya 70
personnes qui habitent à cuzance voulait
faire commande d'importants portée peut
pas travailler
donc il est primé totalement son chiffre
d'affaires s'est pas du tout adapté et
c'est pas le seul car bien évidemment je
me suis amusé à chercher la définition
de la désobéissance civile en préparant
cette interview
plusieurs mais l'une d'entre elles c'est
le refus assumé et public de se
soumettre à une loi et un règlement une
organisation ou un pouvoir jugé inique
par ceux qui le contestent tout en
faisant de ce refus une arme de combat
fès pacifique
la notion date de 1970 même d'avant mais
il a été repris par un philosophe un
john rawls alors la question que vous
pose mettre les principes égalité
liberté ne sont ils pas respecté
aujourd'hui par ces restrictions
sanitaires et notamment par les
restaurateurs qui en sont victimes
l'égalité liberté égalité souvenirs
égalitarisme aujourd'hui on est dans
l'égalitarisme c'est à dire et tout le
monde est sur le même plan vous avez des
entreprises des restaurateurs qui avec
les aides accordées arrive à faire face
et puis vous en avez d'autres c'est le
cas par exemple du chef du rayon qui on
est dans les mondes investissements très
lourds investissements
beaucoup de salariés et qui n'arrivent
pas à faire face donc l'égalité n'est
pas la même pour tous à partir de ce
moment où il ya des situations
profondément différente entre les
restaurateurs
donc on peut pas considérer
qu'aujourd'hui on serait dans l'égalité
on est plutôt dans l'égalitarisme et
l'égalitarisme en général ne prend
jamais en considération les situations
particulières qui sont très nombreuses
faut bien vous il ya une chose c'est que
les chefs qui veulent rouvrir
aujourd'hui c'est pas un caprice si vous
voulez c'est un impératif financier avec
le chef du rayon on a regardé les
chiffres sont clairs si on continue
comme ça allait mais ça peut être le
dépôt de bilan
ça peut être le dépôt de bilan et
brigades et des restaurants qui ouvre de
manière clandestine
un article du parisien qui indiquait
d'ailleurs des magistrats des politiques
des journalistes fréquenté ce type de
restaurant on comprend que c'est pas la
même démarche vous l'avez bien expliquer
puisque le chef turion notamment voulait
ouvrir le dialogue car il le faisait en
indiquant qu'il allait le faire
mais question tout de même ce sera la
dernière l'avocat vous êtes peut-il
cautionner d'une certaine manière le
fait d'enfreindre la loi puisque
finalement c'est tout de même de ce pack
il s'agit au final mais vous l'avez dit
si vous voulez dans une démocratie et
j'ai peur que la notion de démocratie se
perdent profondément pendant cette
période où les choses de paris ça c'est
liberticide si vous voulez le droit à la
désobéissance civile c'est un devoir
constitutionnel
c'est un droit qui existe si vous voulez
on est une république démocratique et on
est une république démocratique et s'est
construit sur ce droit là comment
refuser aux citoyens un moment de lire
long comment refuser aux citoyens de
vouloir le dialogue avec ceux qui sont
censés les représenter
ce qui est choquant dans une démocratie
c'est que ce qui représente le peuple
qui travaille dans l'intérêt du peuple
ne l'écoutent pas voir le méprise est
aujourd'hui le menace et ça c'est très
chaud qu on lave auquel je suis très
attaché à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme
très attaché à la constitution et à
l'application des principes de cette
constitution y compris le droit à
l'insurrection civile pacifique
merci beaucoup en tout cas randall
schwerdorffer d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors question
dictature sanitaires ou bien
restrictions légitime pour protéger les
populations pourront contre la
désobéissance civile dans ce contexte de
crise sanitaire c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
laurent rochus directeur artistique de
la factory avignon au réseau de lieux
dédiés à la pratique est la
représentation des arts vivants avignon
bonsoir laurent rochus à vos côtés pour
en débattre donc noël à jour y président
de l'union des métiers et des industries
de l'hôtellerie nice côte d'azur bonsoir
à vous également merci d'être en direct
sur rt france on en parlait avec maître
chien danseurs certains restaurateurs
qui ont donc décidé d'ouvrir
malgré les interdictions malgré même les
menaces de bruno le maire ce matin je
vous propose d'écouter justement le
ministre de l'économie avant d'en parler
les restaurateurs qui ouvre ne
bénéficieront plus du fonds de
solidarité pendant un mois
et s'il ya récidive ils le perdront tout
court alors question les menaces de
bruno le maire ont-elles casser le
mouvement vous trouvez ça normal ou
choquant à l'instar de l'avocat avec
lequel on vient de s'entretenir n'aurait
la jouerie mais je pense que monsieur le
maire a voulu frapper fort avec cette
annonce ce matin c'est ça qui a fait
freiné un peu si vous voulez les
restaurateurs qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient ouvrir malgré l'interdiction
malgré la fermeture administrative
nous avons appelé depuis plusieurs jours
au calme parce que nous avons eues à
nice un cas d'un restaurateur qui a
voulu braver est en fait née la loi et
qui a ouvert qui a eu des problèmes avec
la justice
je comprends le désarroi
je comprends la tristesse de tous les
restaurateurs de nos collègues
restaurateurs
parce que moi aussi j'ai deux heures à
nice j'ai une vingtaine d'employés je
comprends qu est-ce que c'est des
établissements fermés mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'on va aller contre la loi et
contrôler les décisions administratives
on parle des restaurateurs que vous
représentez ce soir mais ça grogne aussi
du côté des théâtres le nom de la
culture qui souffrent également
laurent rocheux vous même vous avez
lancé samedi l'opération théâtre ouvert
pendant une heure une opération donc
symbolique 1 rapidement interrompues
d'ailleurs par la police ouvrir alors
que vous aviez l'interdiction de fermer
ces de la désobéissance civile pour vous
de l'insurrection ou simplement des
actions coup de poing pour se faire
entendre
non c'était d'abord une interpellation
du ministère qu'on a voulu faire un
raisonnement par l'absurde le fait que
des théâtres où c'est ça qui déclenche
tout l'écosystème de l'art vivant en
france
si les théâtres ne voit pas notamment
l'été acquittent les théâtres qui
achètent des spectacles ce sont les
théâtres municipaux les théâtres qui ont
des régie ou délégation de service
public
aujourd'hui le tout l'art vivant est en
panne à cause de cette ouverture de
théâtre et comme aujourd'hui nous sommes
devant un ministère qui a décidé
d'indemniser l'art vivant avec une un
dispositif qui ne marche pas on est en
train nous sur le terrain d'assister à
une véritable hémorragie et surtout à
une extinction des espèces l'art vivant
en est un est un est un est un domaine
avec des acteurs très plurielle
il ya en gros des institutions qui sont
soutenus par le ministère cela ils sont
mises ont ils ont des fondations en
béton
il ya des entrepreneurs de spectacles
qui sont des grosses boîtes de
production qui financent je dirais une
industrie du divertissement et du et du
loisir culturel sens c'est pas péjoratif
et c'est pas du tout honteux
et puis il y avait aussi énormément et
surtout des artisans qui sont plus ou
moins en avant garde sur la recherche en
création et plus ou moins aidé par les
territoires c'est dans ce vivier là qui
représente plus de la moitié des
compagnies d'arts vivants qu'en ce
moment on va assister je crains d'ici
cet été à une grande déperdition une
extinction des espèces
donc c'est pour appelé le ministère à
faire très attention à cette extinction
d'espèces parce qu'on subodore que ça
pourrait arranger peut-être le ministère
ou en tout cas certaines personnes qu'
il ya un peu moins de productions
théâtrales en france un peu moins de
compagnies qui est une sélection
naturelle qu'on reste un peu dans
l'antre soit des grandes scènes
conventionnées
c'est pour attirer l'attention du
ministère qu'on a fait cette opération
mais si vous voulez
on a piégé un peu si vous voulez
l'institution on a eu des magnifiques
photos de d'agents de police barrant une
porte de théâtre je crois que pour un
régime démocratique comme le nôtre de se
rendre coupable de cette triste pièce
d'avoir des agents de police qui barrent
les bords de théâtre ils nous ont fourni
une image magnifique et puis surtout ça
nous a pas mis nous de prendre le micro
pour interpol et donc roselyne bachelot
sur ce sujet et aussi et surtout la
tirer sur son attention sur l'année
blanche
il faut très vite que l'année blanche
souhaite annoncer le renouvellement de
l'année blanche parce que les
intermittents qui sont complètement
dépendants de ce statut pour pouvoir
imaginer qu'à partir du 1er septembre
prochain ils auront un avenir
professionnel
on peut pas les faire attendre comme
roselyne bachelot à la fin il ya dix
jours disent on va voir on va réfléchir
non on va se retrouver avec huit mois
quasiment 2 saisons éteinte il a la
moindre des choses c'est de leur dire
tout de suite rassurez vous
quand on prend on protège les plus
faibles quoi qu'il en coûte comme il est
le président c'est au plus faible qu'on
doit d'abord à porter cette parole d'h
on va vous aider évidemment on vous
laissera pas avec cette incertitude trop
longtemps au dessus de la tête
en tout cas la faune bon oui on est très
imaginatif donc nous si vous voulez la
prochaine fois on a le ministère de la
parole c'est notre force
le mil le gouvernement à les chiffrer et
à les gendarmes et nous on a
l'imagination et la force de
l'imagination c'est d'être un fini donc
on a eu une idée cette fois c'était de
faire croire qu'on allait ouvrir tous
les théâtres de france pour mettre le
système en panique
la prochaine fois on aura d'autres idées
voilà alors la désobéissance civile en
tout cas c'est un terme employé par de
nombreux politiques en ce moment vous
bénéficiez de soutien dans vos démarches
messieurs comme par exemple florian
philippot le président des patriotes qui
est vent debout contre la fermeture
notamment des restaurants écouter
l'ennemi public numéro 1 est désormais
le restaurateur dix clandestins
c'est à dire qu'ils bossent des ordres
terrible ont été donnés contre eux des
français honnêtes travailleurs qui n'en
peut plus d'être maltraitée par un
pouvoir irresponsable on vit des heures
très sombres
or l'ennemi public c'est le restaurateur
1,7 sentiment que vous avez vous aussi
noël à joris et
le ras-le-bol qui monte alors qu'on le
rappelle quand même un lien il ya des
êtres tout même qu'ils sont accordé des
aides plutôt généreuse en france mais
malgré tout vous avez ce sentiment
d'injustice aujourd'hui mais le
sentiment d'injustice nous l'avons
depuis le début parce que on n'a pas
encore prouvé que les restaurateurs ou
si vous voulez le virus se propage plus
chez les restaurateurs ou dans nos
établissements qu'ailleurs on se base
toujours sur une étude américaine qui
date de plusieurs mois en arrière
la france n'a pas été capable d'apporter
une nouvelle étude fiable devant le
conseil d'état
et malgré ça le conseil d'état a rejeté
notre demande il ya deux mois quand on a
demandé devant le conseil d'état
au nom de notre syndicat la réouverture
de l'établissement concernant le
deuxième volet concernant le deuxième
volet vous dit les aides sont généreuses
je veux des pays comme les etats unis ou
voilà où il n'y a quasiment pas de danse
c'est vrai tout à fait je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous mais n'oubliez
pas que ces aides sont conditionnées
alors et aujourd'hui il y a plus que 35%
voire 40% des restaurateurs n'arrive pas
à toucher ses aides et je dis ça je
parle des restaurateurs sans parler
d'autres métiers sont parlé des
commerçants qui sont fermés qu'on a
obligé à fermer
comment vous expliquez que un
restaurateur qui a ouvert en 2020 n'a
pas le droit aux aides pourquoi c'est
son argent il a investi il s'est endetté
il a mis tout tout tout son argent toute
son énergie pour ouvrir une affaire et
aujourd'hui on lui dit tu fermes dont
l'établissement fin octobre pour la
fermer l'établissement
et quand il demande l'aide ou le fonds
de solidarité on le dit non t'as pas le
droit parce que tu as ouvert en
septembre ou en octobre de l'année
dernière alors que toute l'année
dernière les présidents et le président
des gones le gouvernement des
responsables politiques nous pousser à
investir le pousser tout le monde
seulement les restaurateurs ou c'est
tout le monde à investir en france et
aujourd'hui on leur dit non vous êtes
devant un mur vous n'avez pas le droit
et tous les jours on est confronté à ça
tous les jours mais obligé de passer par
les commissions et des commissions pour
obtenir des aides à ces gens là
et sachez une chose que on aura beaucoup
de malheurs d'ici quelque temps si ça
continue comme ça je n'appelle pas à la
désobéissance civile
pas du tout j'appelle tous les
restaurateurs et tous les commerçants au
calme parce qu'avec le calme qu'on
arrivera peut-être avec le gouvernement
à trouver une solution mais il faut que
le gouvernement nous aide rapidement à
trouver cette solution là que ce soit
pour vous que ce soit pour le théâtre
que ce soit pour l'espé pour les salles
de jeux de sport pour tous les
établissements qui sont frappés
aujourd'hui de fermeture administrative
il faut absolument et en urgence que le
gouvernement monsieur le maire -ministre
de l'économie monsieur le président qui
nous ont dit ils laisseront jamais
personne à la rue de nous aider pour
trouver des solutions rapides parce que
c'est pas vrai tout ce qu'ils ont dit
que aujourd'hui ils nous ont dit que
monsieur le maire a annoncé ce matin que
les centres commerciaux qui sont fermés
depuis hier ils vont avoir
ils vont bénéficier des aides pour les
loyers alors que nous les restaurateurs
nous n'avons pas eu ça les salles de jeu
les restaurateurs voilà qui sont en
colère on l'aura compris on propose
quand même d'écouter aussi l'avis
médical un an l'un des amis parce qu'il
faut bien le dire les médecins ne sont
pas tous d'accord entre eux mais enfin
la montreuil professeur gilbert dorée
chef du service de néphrologie à la
pitié salpêtrière lui et pour un
confinement total les français sont
épuisés par un an de pandémie et de
destruction de l'économie et du tissu
social la seule solution c'est un
confinement total associé à une
vaccination massive
n'ayant pas les doses et pour éviter la
mutinerie des révoltés du confinement
nous procrastine ont alors laurent
rocheux est ce que ce n'est pas ça qu'il
faudrait faire un confinement total
quitte à rouvrir après d'ailleurs
voir l'italie ouvre ses restaurants
notamment aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
écoutez dans l'histoire il ya eu trompe
l'eau des blouses blanches voudrais pas
qu'on ait la république des blouses
blanches
c'est très bien que le gouvernement par
principe de précaution juridique se
cache en permanence derrière des avis
d'experts
mais gouverner c'est aussi prendre des
responsabilités en dehors de ça nous on
est pas du tout là pour expliquer qu'on
ait des infectiologues
encore une fois je répète que notre
action elle n'était pas de dire faut
qu'on rouvre vite s'était attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur le fait
que le dispositif qui est en place pour
indemniser les compagnies je dis bien
des compagnies n'est pas du tout
opérationnel il rend service aux plus
gros et ils laissent les les petits les
indépendants dans une dans une situation
d'hémorragie qui fait qu'ils ne verront
pas l'été et les festivals c'est ça
notre intention donc on va pas débattre
nous les poètes les les histrions avec
avec des infectiologues on a perdu
par contre en tant qu'intellectuel et en
tant que citoyen on peut se poser la
question de ce que signifie qu'à un goût
un gouvernement qui de son olympe
jupitérien interpose entre le peuple et
lui en permanence des experts et court
circuite l'assemblée pour qu'il ait pas
de débat ça c'est autre chose ça je sors
'j'irai de mon rôle de directeur de
théâtre peut-être là mais une fois qu'on
a dit ça
nous on se range derrière david
infectiologues n'a pas du tout envie de
briser des périodes de confinement si on
de nous dire là qu'il faut qu'on finit
drastiquement si suisse mène mais
qu'après la vaccination suivant son
cours
on va pouvoir enfin un petit à petit
aller vers un printemps français
d'ailleurs il faut peut-être se méfier
de ce printemps français on ne sait pas
et un été où les festivals vont enfin
refleurir et que nous cigalon puisse
penser qu'à cigale et voilà notre métier
c'est de faire les cigales et
aujourd'hui on est obligé de prendre les
armes de devenir des fournisseurs
ça nous va pas donc on voudrait très
bien très vite retourner à nos métiers
de cigales et en attendant et bien
confie non s'il faut mais par contre
pendant ce confinement
il faut qu'au ministère on nous entende
il faut vite sécurisé les intermittents
parce que c'est des plus fragiles de
tous les salariés en france parce que
l'enfant leur statut et est très ténue
et qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
laisser dans une expectative où ils se
demandent pour la plupart d'entre eux si
au 1er septembre ils seront pas au rsa
on peut pas laisser les gens sans dormir
avec cette boule au ventre là tous les
soirs c'est inadmissible c'est de la
plus haute et mentale
première chose et puis vite on remet un
petit peu la technicité de
l'indemnisation sur la table on se
réunit en deux trois semaines et je
pense qu'on pourra trouver une façon
d'indemniser les compagnies qui sera
plus légitime et beaucoup qui
corresponde à beaucoup mieux à la
réalité de leurs pertes
voilà c'est tout après nous on laisse se
confie nick s'ils veulent on aura on est
toujours libre dans nos têtes
voilà merci en tout cas tous les deux
laurent rochus noël à jour et d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
dans quelques instants rester avec mon
nous parlerons des restrictions
sanitaires
cette fois ci dans toute l'europe a
requis rencontre de moins en moins
d'adhésion de la population les images
d'émeutes se multiplient comme aux
pays-bas ou encore hier avec des
violences en autriche
et puis direction la birmanie où les
militaires ont commis leur quatrième
coup d'état en 63 ans
l'état d'urgence a été décrété pour un
an
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film à
projets un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature
ça reste un art déco maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for books les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dole à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on les fasse un
tour d'autres acteurs et cnooc mèneront
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france 20h30 heure de
paris partout en europe les
gouvernements s'inquiètent de l'adhésion
de la population en restriction certains
pays limitent la circulation leurs
habitants d'autres font le choix de ne
pas les confiner tour d'horizon des
allègements et des nouvelles mesures
sanitaires mises en place sur le vieux
continent avec noémie via après
plusieurs semaines de fermeture les
musées les centres commerciaux rouvrent
leurs portes en pologne un confinement
partiel de trois semaines et est entrée
en vigueur le 28 décembre sur l'ensemble
du territoire les déplacements le soir
du nouvel an était interdite les centres
commerciaux les hôtels et les stations
de ski devaient fermer leurs portes
seuls les magasins d'alimentation les
pharmacies et d'autres commerces
essentielles sont restés ouverts
lors de cette mise sous cloche en
belgique des mesures drastiques dont la
fermeture des frontières ont été
imposées par le gouvernement des
décisions qui provoque la colère de la
population souffre ici parce que ça n'a
pas du tout fait anormale ce qui ce
passe temps que sarkozy n'est quand même
pas autant partie là on est en train de
la faire crever d'heure énormément de
personnes qui ne peuvent pas travailler
contre offre
le coup en grèce les élèves de collèges
et de lycées vont pouvoir reprendre le
chemin des cours ce lundi à quelques
exceptions près athènes et d'autres
régions en rouge les primaires et les
maternelles elles ont pu rouvrir
il y a trois semaines dans le pays un
confinement strict s'est imposé depuis
le 7 novembre début de l'assouplissement
du confinement stricte mise en place à
chypre dès ce lundi coiffeur et
instituts de beauté pour rouvrir leurs
portes les commerces centres commerciaux
musées et certaines classes dans les
écoles et lycées devront attendre la
semaine prochaine les entreprises
privées pourront à nouveau accueillir 50
% de leurs employés le couvre-feu
nocturne mis en place entre 21h et 5h du
matin restera en place
les restaurants et les bars e
demeureront clos sauf pour les
livraisons et le retrait des commandes
en suisse la quarantaine pour certains
voyageurs étrangers entrent en vigueur
parmi les personnes provenant de la
région provence alpes côte d'azur en
france
l'espagne de chypre du portugal ou
encore d'israël depuis le 18 janvier le
pays a renforcé ses mesures sanitaires
les commerces non essentiels sont fermés
le télétravail est obligatoire lorsque
cela est possible et le port du masque
est exigée dans les entreprises en
espagne les autorités donneront une
conférence de presse sur la situation
sanitaire en fin d'après-midi dans le
pays les restrictions restent différents
d'une région à une autre
le gouvernement écarte l'option d'un
confinement généralisée pour l'instant
le voisin portugais quant à lui a fermé
ses frontières avec madrid pour une
durée de 15 jours
le pays durement frappé par l'épidémie
interdit à sa population les
déplacements non essentiels à l'étranger
cela va durer jusqu'au 14 février à
23h59
avant la fermeture il y a eu un peu de
mouvement dans la zone frontalière
mais en ce moment c'est plus calme et il
n'y a pas trop de trafic le long de la
frontière
je présume que les personnes sont
attentives aux contrôles frontaliers et
respecte les restrictions imposées dans
le pays lors du sommet européen consacré
à la crise sanitaire le 21 janvier
dernier l'union européenne avait tenté
de convaincre les 27 d'opter pour une
réaction coordonnée face au co vide une
tentative vaine pour l'instant et près
des pays bas ou encore le danemark 7 en
autriche que des milliers personnes ont
affronté la police hier à vienne contre
les restrictions liées à la crise
sanitaire des violences à l'issue d'un
rassemblement à l'appel du parti de la
liberté un parti de la droite radicale
retour sur les événements avec nicolas
petit ils ont fait le choix d'aller dans
la rue
dimanche environ dix mille manifestants
ont défilé à vienne à l'appel du parti
nationaliste f p o
et ce malgré l'interdiction de la
manifestation par le gouvernement et la
police je suis ici aujourd'hui avec des
milliers d'autrichiens après que le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé que
toute manifestation critique à l'égard
du gouvernement devrait être interdite
cela m'a mis autant en colère que
beaucoup d'autrichiens nous avons
commencé à nous promener tranquillement
sur le ring street quand soudain
l'ambiance a changé et les gens je
dirais dans un acte de colère justifiée
se sont rendus sur le ring strass il
demande maintenant qu'on leur permette
de manifester que la politique du comité
puisse être discuté publiquement et
surtout que le chanceux les courtes
c'est le ministre ne va moeurs
démissionne lors de la manifestation la
police a dû procéder à des arrestations
alors que la foule refusé de se
disperser et se rendait au parlement
bloquant la circulation
confiné pour la troisième fois juste
après noël les autrichiens doivent
depuis le 25 janvier
respecter une distance de 2 m dans les
lieux publics le port du ffp2 est
également obligatoire dans les magasins
et les transports en commun initialement
prévue le 25 janvier la réouverture des
commerces services musées et écoles a
été reportée au 8 février
une partie de ces autrichiens aux
colères étaient déjà descendus dans la
rue le 16 janvier dernier
il rejette les décisions du chancelier
sebastian kurtz et de son gouvernement
la dernière fois que nous étions ici
lors de la manifestation du 16 janvier
la devise était que cure je devais
simplement partir nous en avons assez
tout le gouvernement doit démissionner
aujourd'hui je suis ici pour nos enfants
mes petits enfants nos aînés qui doivent
mourir seul dans des maisons de retraite
ou dans des hôpitaux sans compagnie de
façon dégradante pour nos enfants qui
doivent toujours mettre leurs masques à
l'école ce n'est pas possible et c'est
pour cela que je suis ici
malgré les restrictions imposées par le
gouvernement
l'autriche a enregistré dimanche 1190
nouvelles infections au coronavirus dans
l'actualité également coup de force de
l'armée en birmanie les militaires se
sont emparés du pouvoir tout ce matin et
deux ont proclamé l'état d'urgence pour
une période d'un an pl sont des généraux
principaux postes du pays et chef du
gouvernement civil and sun tzu chi a été
arrêté alors que le parlement issu des
dernières législatives devaient entamer
sa première session des événements qui
ont fait réagir la communauté
internationale hélène masquelier
il est 3 heures du matin à rangoon la
capitale économique du pays
les télécommunications sont brouillées
quand se répand la nouvelle de
l'arrestation donc sans souci dénoncé
par son parti nous avons entendu dire
qu'elle est détenue à naypidaw nous
supposons que l'armée est en train
d'organiser un coup d'état lors d'un
discours officiels diffusés sur sa
chaîne de télévision l'armée a décrété
l'état d'urgence pour un an promettant
la tenue prochaine d'élections dans la
tente le pouvoir et confié au commandant
en chef le général min-soo et au l'armée
birmane il s'agit de préserver la
stabilité dans le pays
les militaires dénoncent une fraude lors
des élections législatives qui se sont
tenues en novembre dernier remportée
massivement par le parti donc santucci
tamada haut le nom officiel de l'armée
birmane avait mis en garde la semaine
dernière contre un possible coup d'état
tamatave défendra la constitution contre
les organisations nationales ou
internationales qui ne la respecte pas
et ne la suivent pas et qui sont de
mauvaise volonté contre la constitution
parce que tu as matin au fait partie de
l'état et du public
nous ne disons pas que tu as matin on va
prendre le pouvoir
nous ne disons pas qu'il ne le fera pas
les relations entre les militaires et le
gouvernement ont toujours été
compliquées le pouvoir en birmanie est
partagée dans un système hybride
l'armée contrôle en trois ministères
clés dans le pays l'intérieur la défense
et celui des frontières ce lundi matin
la communauté internationale a vivement
réagi les etats unis menacent de prendre
des mesures contre les responsables
la chine presse le pays à régler ces
différends
paris tokyo londres ou encore l'onu
condamne fermement l'arrestation de la
dame de rangoon
ces développements porte un coup dur aux
réformes démocratiques en birmanie
tous les dirigeants doivent agir dans le
plus grand intérêt de la réforme
démocratique en birmanie s'engager dans
un dialogue constructif s'abstenir de
toute violence et respecter pleinement
les droits de l'homme et les libertés
fondamentales des partisans de l'armée
défilent dans les rues de rangoon en
scandant des hymnes aux nationalistes
tandis que les militaires se sont
désormais emparé de l'hôtel de ville
l'accès à l'aéroport internationale
reste bloquée et de nombreux soldats
sont déployés dans les rues de la
capitale n'a pizza aux dix ans plus tard
ce matin pourrait signer le retour au
pouvoir des militaires qui avait dirigé
le pays pendant près d'un demi siècle
et pour en parler mon sens avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
bonsoir claude à blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à la première question pourquoi l'armée
at-elle perpétuer perpétrés par dont un
coup d'état
l'armée n'a pas accepté le résultat des
élections législatives du mois de
novembre dernier
c'est le parti de mme allard en dessous
qui les a très largement gagné et
l'armée qui ne pouvait pas accepter ce
résultat a dit qu'il y avait eu des
fraudes s'est retourné vers la
commission électorale qui a confirmé le
résultat des élections est en effet
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
dans votre sujet ce nouveau parlement
devait se réunir aujourd'hui et avait
donc urgence pour
militaire à agir d'autant plus que ce
nouveau parlement devait élire d'ici le
mois de mars un nouveau président de la
république et que le parti de madame
aung san suu kyi avait bien attention dû
faire discuter de réformes
constitutionnelles
les réformes constitutionnelles
porterait sur les privilèges dont
bénéficient les militaires puisque dans
le début de la transition ce sont les
militaires qui ont écrit la constitution
en 2008
et c'est en vertu de cette constitution
qu'ils détiennent 25% des sièges dans
chacune des deux assemblées et que c'est
peut-être au stade actuel de l'évolution
c'était peut-être en effet un vestige du
passé de la même façon que leur contrôle
absolu du ministère des armées du
ministère de l'intérieur et les
frontières sans avoir à rendre compte au
gouvernement
donc en plus il était très inquiet de le
développement de la lutte contre la
corruption que madame aung san suu kyi
avait engagé et santé certains de leurs
intérêts menacés up ailleurs ils ont
sans doute choisi cette époque parce que
il est vrai que l'aura de madame aung
san suu kyi avait un peu pâli
lorsqu'elle avait elle n'avait pas pris
la défense des rohingya l'héroïne gars
si cette minorité musulmane qui a été
très mal traités et chassé de son
territoire et sont maintenant réfugiés
un peu partout mais notamment au
bangladesh et en retour ceux qui avaient
même été défendre la position officielle
du gouvernement birman à la cour de
justice internationale à la haye
probablement les militaires ont fait une
erreur de calcul
ils ont écrit ils ont cru que les toiles
de balle absence ou qui avaient un peu
pâli en réalité tous les pays
occidentaux naturellement prennent
aujourd'hui sa défense est-ce que
clairement trop blanches raison on peut
dire que c'est un coup porté au
processus démocratique en birmanie
oui bien sûr puisque c'était un
processus comme vous le comme vous le
dites il était engagé et qui devait se
poursuivre la participation
les sièges réservés aux militaires dans
les assemblées étaient quelque chose de
provisoire
le fait que des ministères échapper au
contrôle du gouvernement était aussi
provisoire par conséquent la réforme
devaient se poursuivre or là les
militaires procèdent un retour en
arrière en décrétant l'état d'urgence en
suspendant le parlement est probablement
pendant cette année d'état d'urgence
ils vont essayer d'élaborer une des
textes qui garantissent les privilèges
dont ils bénéficient actuellement ils
veulent continuer à contrôler
l'essentiel de l'activité
gouvernementale
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la loi et
l'ordre en ce qui concerne la sécurité
extérieure
et en ce qui concerne les frontières
alors c'est très ennuyeux pour le pays
parce que lorsque le processus de
libéralisation avait commencé les pays
occidentaux pour l'encourager avait levé
les sanctions économiques et il ya donc
des investissements qui se sont faits en
birmanie et qui aujourd'hui risquent
d'être remis en question alors pékin et
les autres voisins de la birmanie appel
à régler ce différend quels sont les
enjeux pour ces pays là la chine et la
grande voisine c'est le principal
partenaire économique et la chine
construit beaucoup l'infrastructure en
birmanie elle construit un corridor pour
relier le territoire chinois à l'océan
indien la même façon qu'elle le fait
beaucoup plus à l'ouest de l'autre côté
de l'inde au pakistan est donc pour elle
l'essentiel c'est que le calme règne
dans le pays et qu' il n'y ait pas de
guerre civile naturellement dans ce pays
c'est pour elle le point essentiel mais
elle a appelé aujourd'hui à ce que les
différents soit résolu suivant les
termes de la constitution c'est-à-dire
en fait suivant les termes que
souhaitent les militaires faisant
peut-être abstraction du résultat des
élections législatives du mois de
novembre pour les autres pays d'asie
l'inde est embarrassée parce qu' elle ne
veut pas laisser la birmanie tomber
complètement dans le giron de la chine
d'ailleurs elle avait promis il ya
quinze jours d'envoyer 1
deux millions de doses de vaccins vite
vaccins des vaccins indien aux birmans
et elle va le faire certainement la
chine va évidemment en envoyer au temps
où un peu plus que ce qui est vraie
rivalité entre ces deux pays pour
influencer la birmanie pour le reste la
birmanie est un des dix pays d'asie du
sud est qui fait partie de ce groupement
des pays d'asie chine est ce qu'on
appelle la zad et qui est un groupement
qui est surtout intéressé par en faire
une zone de paix en utilisant notamment
les échanges économiques
le libre échange et dans les pays de la
zale on a pour habitude de ne pas
critiquer le régime politique du voisin
d'autant plus que les régimes politiques
sont très différents il ya à l'intérieur
des zean de régime communiste le vietnam
et le laos un régime à parti dominant
très dominant le cambodge un pays qui a
connu un coup d'état militaire et dont
il se sort ce coup d'état militaire
continue à produire ces résultats c'est
la thaïlande
et puis d'autres pays qui ont des
élections et qui sont plus démocratiques
comme la malaisie comme les philippines
ou comme ou comme il ya aussi par
exemple par dont j'allais l'oublier
le sultanat de brunei il lui évidemment
et un régime
tout à fait autoritaire donc à l'asian
on ne critique pas le régime des voisins
et il est probable que l'adn sera
surtout intéressés par le fait qu' on
trouve une solution pacifique à la crise
actuelle et que ça ne dégénère pas en
guerre civile
merci claude blanche maison pour votre
analyse mais n'y fait
manifestation pro davani ce dimanche
encore dans plus de 80 villes russes
pour le second week-end d'affilée
des milliers de personnes ont été
arrêtées les protestataires réclament la
libération de l'opposant alexeï navalni
incarcéré depuis son retour en russie le
17 janvier dernier
ses partisans ont prévu de se rassembler
devant le tribunal de moscou où
l'opposant doit être jugé l excellent
avenir pourrait être condamnée pour ne
pas avoir respecté les conditions de sa
peine de prison avec sursis et dans le
même temps le service fédéral de
sécurité russe a publié des images qui
montrent une rencontre secrète présumés
entre l'un des associés les plus proches
de navalni et un officier du
renseignement britannique il ya quelques
temps
selon le fsb la grande bretagne est
étroitement lié à l'opposition russe et
fournit un soutien financier et des
renseignements à ses membres
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec mourad ghazli f sur la liste rt
internationale bonsoir moi deux gaziers
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france le service fédéral de sécurité
russe qui publie donc des images qui
montrent clairement une réunion secrète
entre l'un des associés les plus proches
de navalni et un officier du
renseignement britannique qui aurait eu
lieu il ya quelques temps
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur cette
rencontre présumée même jeu décisif où
emma qui mentionne toutefois que la
secousse
lorsque le second s'est prêté aux
affaires politiques de ne pas saturer
tous rencontrés dans un restaurant
moscovite chaque main de l'opposition
vladimir h aux cavs le bras droit
d'alexei davani aschoff vu l'intérieur
royer momus et ses 8 ans il prend
toujours pas à un mouvement de
l'opposition en russie
maintenant que nous avons vu cette vidéo
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes concernant
la relation entre le royaume uni et
l'opposition russe des relations qui
pourraient être du bien plus forte qu'on
ne le pensait auparavant
car si l on écoute les peintures à chaud
de cette vidéo
monsieur h horcoff semble sous-entendre
qu'ils ont besoin de financements
supplémentaires
et pourquoi ces images n'ont plus
d'argent nous agrandir y ont bien sûr
notre été un peu d'argent si quelqu'un
dépensé je ne sais pas à 10 20 millions
de dollars par an pour soutenir cela
nous verrions les choses différemment
[Rires]
ce n'est pas une grosse somme d'argent
pour des gens qui ont des milliards en
jeu c'est donc le message que j'essaie
de faire passer dans le cadre de ma
campagne de collecte de feuilles
notamment parlons aujourd'hui monde des
affaires externes
voilà on vient donc de voir cette vidéo
pourquoi ces images sont-elles diffusé
maintenant il semble si heureux que ceux
qui finançait l'opposition
brouillon on pourrait récupérer des
milliards
alami a dit vous pourriez récupérer des
milliards une fois que l'opposition
serait au pouvoir
il ne spécifie pas à quelle somme mais
en tout cas bien plus que cet argent
dont il parle il évoque l'idée
d'empêcher les entreprises russes par
exemple de faire des affaires en europe
il explique comment il envisage est
arrivé au pouvoir en organisant des pros
des manifestations de masse il parle de
propagande
également il parle de propagande contre
la dirif poutine donc beaucoup de
questions sont suscitées par à cette
vidéo alors selon le fsb la grande
bretagne et est étroitement lié à
l'opposition russe et fournit un soutien
financier des renseignements à ses
membres quels sont les éléments qui
accréditent cette thèse en position
figure
regardez le nombre des figures de
l'opposition s'ils vivent au royaume uni
enseignement un cadre du colloque de la
fondation d'accès ne va ni à trouver
l'asile politique
beaucoup d'autres membres de 7
organisation se trouve au royaume-uni et
cela est à ton histoire
vous connaissez par exemple ne s'inscrit
pas là qui avait été condamné pour
traîtrise qui avait transféré d
organisation secrète alors qu'il
travaillait pour la russie à horoya
mouly et bien il a été transféré au
royaume uni et là bas il a également
reçu un permis de résidence
donc il ya une longue histoire de
relations entre le royaume et les
opposants politiques russes et deux
touchés j'ai commencé mon récit en
rappelant et l'histoire qui remonte à
2006 le second secrétaire aux affaires
politiques de l'ambassade du royaume uni
matou à l'époque s'est retrouvé impliqué
dans un scandale à scandales autour
d'une fausse pierre qui était utilisé
comme appareil de communication secret
donc il y a une histoire d'espionnage
britannique en russie et en 2019 il y
avait un projet est une initiative
integrity ce projet était financé par le
royaume uni est soutenu par le royaume
uni qui rassemblait des journalistes
avec un programme anti russe en 2019 il
ya eu des fuites de documents montrant
que le gouvernement britannique avait
versé 20 mille livres à des alliés
de nava libyen que ses alliés en
question est niée donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments qui indiquent des
liens entre la les services de
renseignement britanniques et les
activités de l'opposition russe beaucoup
de questions aussi quels seraient les
intérêts de la grande bretagne a aidé le
canada ni la question est très simple
quel serait l'intérêt de quiconque y
avoir des amis à la tête d'un autre pays
aussi cela a causé beaucoup de remous ce
scandale
notamment parce que si l'opposition
travail
effectivement même si cela n'a pas été
complètement prouvé avec le royaume uni
et bien c'est grave
il faut savoir que le royaume uni a
refusé de commenter cette vidéo disant
qu'il refuse de commenter les fuites
donc voilà une vidéo où des membres de
l'opposition et 10 ha à une personne que
le fsb considère comme un agent du mi6
disant nous allons vous donner des
informations permettant de bannir des
entreprises telles que la seconde plus
importante banque russe de l'europe et
cela va vous aider parce que les banques
britanniques tels que love to barre
qu'ils auront moins de concurrence
pouvez vous imaginer par exemple 1
socialiste du parti socialiste français
le vice président par exemple du parti
socialiste captés dans une vidéo en
train de discuter avec un agent du
renseignement chinois lui expliquant
comment ils travaillent afin que les
entreprises françaises ne puisse plus
travailler en chine afin que les
entreprises chinoises et moins de
concurrents c'est exactement la
situation dont nous parlons à shokof
face caméra depuis qu'il a présenté des
preuves gouvernement britannique que des
entreprises britanniques des entreprises
russes devraient être interdits de
travailler en europe et en rajoutant
cela serait une bonne chose pour vous
donc cela a causé cela causerait un
tollé en france cela serait la fin de la
carrière politique qu'il avait personne
en question
voici pourquoi 7 cette information a
causé beaucoup de romans en russie
pourquoi cela suscite beaucoup de
conversation et à juste titre il
pourrait s'agir d'un risque pour la
sécurité de la russie question magasin
rapidement est-ce que d'autres agences
de renseignement pourrait être en lien
avec le clan n'avaient ni pourrez pas
vous le dire je n'ai pas accès aux
banques de données des renseignements
russes
je ne je n'ai pas toute l'information
dont le fsb dispose cela fait huit ans
qu'ils ont cette vidéo et beaucoup de
russes d'ailleurs demande mais pourquoi
cette vidéo n'a t'elle pas était
diffusée plus tôt pourquoi avez vous
attendu 8 9 ans pourquoi la publier
maintenant
c'est d'altérer public de savoir que des
citoyens russes discute avec que les
renseignements britanniques afin que les
citoyens sachent pour qu'ils votent mais
l espionnage c'est l'espionnage
cela ne monte pas cela remonte à
longtemps et cela va continuer longtemps
différents états en différents critères
de sécurité et certains critères le
porte être validée que si lens est ce
que font les autres pays les relations
de la russie avec d'autres étaient ne
sont pas très bonnes donc il serait
logique que la france par exemple
finances
une opposition qui leur est plus
amicales les etats unis ont traversé
quatre ans de crise parce que l'on
croyait il n'y a pas de vidéo de
documents montrant donald trump
discutant avec des diplomates russes ne
s'agissait que de rumeurs et pourtant
les états unis ont passé quatre ans en
prison parce qu'on soupçonnait que
donald trump avait des liens avec des
connivences avec le kremlin avec le
renseignement russe donc c'est un sujet
de préoccupation majeur et je certain
que beaucoup agences de renseignement
dans le monde ont des liens non
seulement avec l'opposition russe mais
également avec le gouvernement russe
c'est la façon dont ça marche
merci moura da gazière journalistes rt
internationale d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la bataille des vaccins qui se joue
en europe cire des laboratoires
permettre d'accélérer la production de
vaccins bruxelles reste pointé du doigt
pour sa gestion et puis direction
ensuite israël
la campagne de vaccination bat son plein
mais l'état hébreu a dû se résoudre hier
à prolonger de cinq jours les mesures de
confinement à cause de la hausse du
nombre de personnes contaminées
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça l'est il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie bat évidemment
on s'embête il faut sortir les notes de
leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
oui
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 1er février
les laboratoires promettent d'accélérer
la production de vaccins l'europe pointé
du doigt pour sa gestion prévient que
les mois de février et de mars seront
difficiles bruxelles annonce qu'elle
recevrait au premier trimestre en
passant de doses en plus d'astrazeneca
enfin les herbiers intec temps d'ici peu
jusqu'à 75 millions de doses
supplémentaires à l'union européenne au
deuxième trimestre pendant que l'europe
tape du poing sur la table pour obtenir
des doses israël continue de mener
tambour battant sa campagne de
vaccination c'est chose faite pour un
tiers de la population
si l'état hébreu a dû se résoudre hier à
prolonger de cinq jours les mesures de
confinement à cause de la hausse du
nombre de personnes contaminées
les premiers effets de la stratégie
vaccinale seraient eux bien perceptible
coup d'envoi de l'examen du projet de
loi contre le séparatisme aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale destinée à
renforcer l'arsenal contre l'islamisme
radical en france est un texte
d'équilibré selon le gouvernement
l'opposition elle le fustigent les
républicains dévoilant un contre-projet
demain côté religion protestants juifs
catholiques et mesures
des noms chinois qui met les cultes sous
tutelle paris serait-il de retour dans
les négociations du traité de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et le
mercosur c'est l'inquiétude de plusieurs
ong et représentants du monde agricole
alors que le gouvernement travaillerait
sur les conditions d'une levée de son
veto emmanuel macron affirmé lui depuis
plusieurs mois être reposé en teck au
texte par dont l'état qui contribuent à
la déforestation et au réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]
face à la colère de l'union européenne
les laboratoires promettent des efforts
kaiser biotech a annoncé jusqu'à 75
millions de doses supplémentaires de son
vaccin au deuxième trimestre pour
l'union européenne
astrazeneca de son côté livrera 9
millions de doses de plus que prévu soit
40 millions au total
un chiffre en hausse de 30% une nouvelle
qui devrait permettre d'apaiser les
tensions entre bruxelles et londres
le laboratoire suédois au britannique
étant soupçonné de vouloir favoriser le
royaume uni dans ses livraisons
amaya souple et la course aux injections
se poursuit au royaume uni le
gouvernement britannique met les
bouchées doubles pour atteindre ses
objectifs
si la situation reste toujours compliqué
outre manche
la campagne de vaccination elle monte en
puissance
désormais les pharmacies sont mises à
contribution
certaines vaccine jusqu'à 1200 personnes
par semaine
de nombreux centres sont ouverts 24h sur
24 boris johnson a affiché un projet
ambitieux 15 millions de personnes
vaccinées d'ici mi février
à ce jour huit millions d'habitants ont
pu bénéficier du sérum contre le coc
vide 19 après avoir approuvé trois
vaccins le premier ministre britannique
a annoncé ce jeudi avoir obtenu 60
millions de doses d'un nouveau vaccin
développé par l'américain nova nax est
en cours de validation par londres les
autorités sanitaires britanniques
libérés de toute contrainte avec l'
agence européenne du médicament
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du break
sites ont donc pu accélérer les
autorisations
une aubaine pour le pays qui a donc pu
commencer sa vaccination dès le début du
mois de décembre mais la campagne est
entachée par l'émergence d'un conflit
avec bruxelles
confronté à des retards
d'approvisionnement de la part des
différents laboratoires
l'union européenne a mis en place ce
vendredi un système de contrôle des
exportations de vaccins une décision
forte qui visait également l'irlande du
nord mais l'accord de break site prévoit
de ne pas réinstaurer de frontière entre
la province britannique et la république
d'irlande est indépendant membre de
l'union européenne après les
protestations de boris johnson
bruxelles a finalement fait marche
arrière pour ne pas compromettre les
accords établis quand des amis font des
erreurs la chose la plus importante à
faire et d'aider chacun à se remettre
sur la bonne voie donc oui une erreur a
été commise hier mais je pense qu'il est
également important de reconnaître que
si nous devons donner la priorité à la
vaccination des citoyens britanniques
il est aussi dans notre intérêt de
soutenir nos amis et voisins dans leurs
programmes de vaccination et nous le
ferons en veillant à ce que les contrats
soient respectés que les promesses
soient tenues et que les citoyens
britanniques soient vaccinés en premier
un rétropédalage de l'union européenne
qui n'efface pas ce couac diplomatique
entre les deux parties un mois après le
départ officiel du royaume uni comme un
signe des futures relations houleuses
entre londres et bruxelles la ministre
au commerce international britannique a
annoncé ce samedi un projet d'adhésion à
l'accord de libre échange transpacifique
demande déposée dès ce lundi 1er février
et à paris en marge d'une rencontre avec
le président serbe et bene macron après
l'union européenne être plus solidaire
face au co vite sur la question des
vaccins justement vous propose d'écouter
j'aurais souhaité d'ailleurs que la
france et l'europe puisse être à vos
côtés davantage présents sur le sujet
des vaccins
je salue votre engagement la matière et
votre volontarisme
je veux vous dire en tout cas que nous
ferons tous dans la durée pour pour vous
pour pouvoir être à vos côtés et aux
côtés du peuple serbe et de tous les
peuples de la région
c'est une course de vitesse que nous
menons contre le virus
vous l'avez fait avec beaucoup de
volontarisme d'esprit de responsabilité
que je veux ici saluer mais je pense que
nous européens devons aussi avoir encore
plus d'efficacité sur ce sujet je sais
que c'est également la volonté de la
chancelière merkel de la présidente von
der leyen et nous continuerons dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois a accéléré les choses pour aller
plus vite sur ce sujet l'égard de nos
populations mais mieux accompagner aussi
nos amis et pour en parler des vaccins
mais aussi faire un point sur les autres
traitements nous sommes en direct avec
jean ferrat
grenoble elle pas bonsoir jean paul
stahl merci d'être avec nous les vaccins
justement sujet très politique car on
vient de le constater lors qui hausse le
ton face aux laboratoires c'est la seule
façon de s'en sortir aujourd'hui pour
vous c'est la solution
il n'y a pas d'autre les pâtes aux deux
façons de faire en attendant c'est le
les mesures barrières bien entendu mais
le vaccin ou les vaccins
c'est la seule solution à long terme n'a
pas d'autres alors jean paul stahl
astrazeneca on en parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui inquiets augmenté ses doses
des doutes concernant les personnes
âgées qui persistent quant aux
performances de ce produit alors que
l'agencé du médicament européenne elle
pour le moment a donné son aval pour
toutes les populations au dessus de 18
ans est ce qu'il faudrait prendre la
décision en france en tout cas était
peut-être partout en europe de le
réserver uniquement aux étudiants c'est
ce que propose le député centriste jean
christophe lagarde par exemple ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas entendable
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas décréter
qu'une population womé vaut une
meilleure protection que l'autre donc ça
ça non par contre que des vaccins et des
performances différentes en fonction
effectivement des dés de leurs modes
finalement technologique
ça c'est pas très sympa très surprenante
mais ça doit s'intégrer dans une une
stratégie très général c'est pas juste
ceci je le réserve à tel à telle ou
telle ça c'est pas pensable
mais jean pas le style c'est justement
parce qu'on ignore et on doute surtout
beaucoup de l'efficacité au delà des
plus de 65 ans donc par conséquent ne
faudrait-il pas le réserver
aux plus jeunes on pourrait on pourrait
effectivement décidé ça mais encore une
fois ça s'intègre dans une stratégie
générale c'est à dire que certains
vaccins pourraient être donnés
prioritairement à une catégorie de
population et l autre à d'autres
catégories de population
effectivement si ça s'intègre dans une
stratégie générale avec effectivement
des cibles particulières pourquoi pas
donc ça nous amènerait à changer la
stratégie vaccinale s'appelle sache ça
amènerait à évoluer en tout cas c'est à
dire que les vaccins et rennes qui ont
une efficacité très largement supérieure
à tous les autres pour l'instant serait
pourrait être effectivement réservé ou
tout au moins
destiné prioritairement aux personnes
les plus à risque les autres vaccins
pourraient être destinés aux personnes
moins à risque alors on imagine qu'on
n'aura pas franchement le choix du
vaccin est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
inégalité justement vous le dites vous
même il ya plus d'efficacité pour le
moment sur les vaccins arn messagers
peut-être moins sur les autres alors qu
on ne va pas pouvoir choisir ça ne pose
pas un problème en terme justement de
consentement des populations
alors pour le consentement il faut
expliquer mais expliquer ma foi ça cela
peut se comprendre parfaitement que
c'est à dire que imaginons un vaccin qui
est efficace à 80% dans une certaine
population qui est à très haut risque
effectivement ça vous laisse idée des
risques très important d'être d'être
infectés et d'être malade gravement mais
par contre la même efficacité à 80% dans
une population ou le risque de
l'événement grave et très faible ça a
finalement assez peu de conséquences
pratiques
donc c'est comme ça qu'il faut raisonner
aujourd'hui j'en parle ce talent quand
vous voyez
les objectifs ambitieux du gouvernement
la matière est ce que vous êtes
optimiste vous êtes confiant sur
l'évolution de sa maladie parce que
c'est vrai que beaucoup s'inquiètent
aujourd'hui les choses vont plutôt de
mal en pis et ce au niveau de la planète
en raison notamment des variants alors
c'est ça dépend je veux dire je ne sais
pas ce que vont pouvoir livrer les les
fabricants de vaccins que ce soient les
plus avancés ou ce soit ce qui arrive ça
a marché
quelles sont les quantités qu'ils sont
capables de de mettre sur le marché si
on peut parler comme ça pour pour
vacciner la population
donc là tout est là quelle est la
capacité de production
en attendant ce moment là il faut dire
et redire que la prévention ce sont les
gestes barrière aujourd'hui évidemment
on entend tout et son contraire dans la
presse sur les chaînes d'information on
entendait ce matin chez certains de nos
confrères voilà que le variant brésilien
est bien le vaccin n'était pas efficace
en la matière est ce que vous vous avez
des informations fiables où on ne sait
toujours rien ont finalement sur cette
épidémie
non il n'ya pas deux il ya pas de
données scientifiques sérieuses publié
là dessus donc pour l'instant
et en plus toutes les données et
théoriques sont en faveur du maintien de
l'efficacité des vaccins actuellement
disponibles il faut bien il faut bien
savoir que la mule les mutations dont on
parle
les variants ces mutations porte sur une
voire deux protéines le vaccin lui il
entraîne une humidité sur une large
vingtaine de protéines différentes donc
et si on a une sur lesquels c'est moitié
moins efficace il en reste quand même un
certain nombre qui permet d'obtenir une
immunité vaccinale tout à fait
acceptable on est on est plutôt soulagé
de l'entendre en tout cas qu'en est il
des autres traitements parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de vaccins et on ne parle plus
des autres traitements par des gestes
barbe de barrières mais pas des autres
médicaments
comment la colchicine on en a beaucoup
parlé ces derniers jours
vous y croyez à ses autres traitements
ou c'est un échec ni je dois y croire ni
pas y croire j'attends simplement une
démonstration
j'ai un peu peur la colchicine fasse le
même effet que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
c'est à dire une démonstration de
l'efficacité nul ce que je remarque pas
cependant c'est qu'il ya aucune aucune
publication scientifique qui atteste de
l'efficacité de tous ces médicaments
divers et variés loria colchicine la
vitamine d enfin et cetera et cetera
autant de autant de deux possibilités
mais qui ont été communiquées par voie
de communiqué de presse
c'était pas de la communication
scientifique et j'ai très sincèrement
pour l'instant moi je ne vois aucun mais
alors aucun le traitement efficace les
avis de celui m6 merci jean par le stade
infectiologues au chu à grenade d'avoir
été à grenoble alpes d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france hongrie à
présent le pays bouscule les codes au
sein de l'union européenne son
gouvernement et des autorités sanitaires
ont validé en l'espace de 10 jours les
vexant russes et chinois sans attendre
l'accord de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments
cette dernière n'ayant validé pour
l'heure que ce délai bordeaux
laboratoire américain pfizer moderna le
vexin allemand de biotech et celui de
britanniques d'astrazeneca la stratégie
vaccinale hongroise
grande première pour un pays membre de
l'ue eux pourraient ainsi faire
jurisprudence walid bennani fort de ces
accords russo chinois la hongrie prête à
frapper un grand coup au sein de l'union
européenne
bisous cameron diaz a comme martin ac
nous espérons que ces vaccins seront
disponibles en grandes quantités et que
le processus de vaccination pourra donc
se dérouler beaucoup plus largement en
plus grand nombre et en moins de temps
cela serait très important et pertinent
pour la gestion de l'épidémie
quinze années 5.15 un pique adressée à
bruxelles
le gouvernement hongrois et son premier
ministre en colère contre l' agence
européenne des médicaments
jugée trop lente pour approuver chaque
nouveau vaccin
vendredi 22 janvier à moscou la hongrie
a affiché une nouvelle stratégie qui
pourrait bien donner quelques idées à
ses voisins de lieux en raison de la
lenteur de la livraison des vaccins nous
devions trouver une nouvelle source à
partir de laquelle nous pourrions nous
approvisionner rapidement en un vaccin
fiable
c'est pourquoi c'est un grand honneur et
un grand plaisir pour moi que nous
aurions signé un accord par lequel la
russie fournira le vaccin sur le
territoire de la hongrie en trois étapes
trois étapes trois envois différents et
jusqu'à 2 millions de doses commandées
le vaccin spoutnik v a reçu une
autorisation de six mois de l'institut
national hongrois de pharmacie et de
nutrition sa première livraison fera
budapest est annoncée pour fin février
le vaccin russe jugée fiable à plus de
90% par moscou n'est pas encore entré en
procédure d'examen du côté de l' agence
européenne du médicament
la russie a déposé une demande
d'homologation le 20 janvier après avoir
affirmé ces dernières semaines que plus
d'un million cinq cent mille personnes
ont déjà utilisé spoutnik v dans le
monde
s'il n'y a pas de vaccin de l'union
prenons le ailleurs il n'est pas
possible que les hongrois meurent à
cause de ça nous recevrons des vaccins
des russes chinois américains nous
parlons avec les israéliens pendant que
nous attendons que bruxelles tente de
gérer tant bien que mal la situation
un gouvernement hongrois heureux
d'annoncer il ya quelques jours
l'autorisation également sur son
territoire du vaccin chinois sinopharm 5
millions de doses achetées et livrés en
quatre mois une nouvelle stratégie
vaccinale rendue possible grâce à la
signature d'un décret qui pourrait bien
faire des émules
ce dernier permet à tout vaccin ayant
déjà été administré à plus d'un million
de personnes est utilisé dans trois pays
au moins d'être homologué en hongrie
l'un de ces trois pays se doit d'être
membre de l'union européenne ou à défaut
candidat à son adhésion et en israël
justement c'est la campagne de
vaccination est mené de façon intensive
le gouvernement a quand même dû se
résoudre hier à prolonger à 200 jours
les mesures de confinement en cause le
nombre de personnes contaminées qui ne
cesse d'augmenter
une réunion est prévue mercredi afin
d'examiner à nouveau la situation une
troisième mise sous cloche mais les
premiers effets de la vaccination serait
perceptible
le professeur cyrille cohen immunologue
observe une chute des infections de 50%
à une chute des hospitalisations 40%
comme il l'a révélé à nos collègues de
france info et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis tel aviv avec
paula slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir collet slayer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un tiers
des israéliens qui ont déjà été
vaccinées mais nouveau confinement on
peut dire que la stratégie est bonne
mais que cela prend du temps
je pense que la plupart des israéliens
notamment les experts du gouvernement
seraient déclassées expliqué que la
consommation devrait atteindre ses
objectifs d'ici à la fin mars à ses est
en bonne voie mais il faudra plusieurs
semaines avant l'égalisation de mener
comme vous l'avez dit un tiers des
citoyens israéliens et et lévesque
sommet c'est-à-dire avec 3 millions de
personnes 3 millions de personnes et 1
17 million de personnes ont reçu les
deux doses avec tu es bien sûr et une
période de 21 jours entre les deux
factions vaccination israël utilise les
accents pfizer mais également parfois le
vaccin modern guilt le pays est
actuellement confiné le confinement a
été prolongée jusqu'à vendredi à 19h et
le cabinet ministériel se rassemblera
mercredi afin de décider si le
confinement va encore être en danger
le 1er mai sera le seul italien on pense
qu'il devrait être prolongé donc on
pense que la stratégie est bonne même si
les chiffres restent encore inquiétant
il serait elle si j'ose dire
mais vraiment le paquet dans la lutte
contre ce virus ce sont deux armes le
confinement dont vous venez parler et le
vaccin qu'on a payé plus cher en israël
qu'il faut combiner c'est vraiment le
prix à payer on est convaincu de cela
dans l'état hébreu
je pense que les gens en sont convaincus
le bon c'est bien qu'ils seraient là à
payer bien plus que d'autres vies pour
le vaccin un taux moyen de 47 dollar par
personne
le l'israélien moyen ne paye pas lui
même le vaccin et l'assurance sont
charge mais cette différence et car les
bâtiments c'est arrivé une plus
rapidement en israël et ont été
commandés en masse ses 350 milliards de
dollars pour le vaccin mais c'est une
meilleure option pour l'économie par
rapport à un confinement de continuer
vous avez également mentionné le méconnu
en général le taux de chômage est à 11%
en israël c'est un record sur les 15
dernières années l'économie souffre et
le dernier confinement gouttes 1,3
milliard de dollars par semaine
cependant il ya également les aéroports
qui ont été fermés ce qui signifie qu'il
n'ya plus de tourisme mais le tourisme
n'est pas un secteur majeur les israël
se fondent plutôt sur les technologies
de pointe qui permet beaucoup le
télétravail et dont qui serait souffrant
moins que d'autres pays
l'état hébreu qui a payé plus cher mais
qui a été aussi mieux servis par ce
qu'elle a accepté de fournir les données
un des personnes vaccinées
et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle si j'ose
dire du jour ans et que manifestement
les premières données sont plutôt
optimistes avec des bons résultats
perceptibles
on a donné les chiffres tout à l'heure
vous nous confirmer cela il ya de vrais
bons aux résultats sur ces vacciner je
suis allée terrain on considère
effectivement que le pays avance sa
façon à bord y voir l'effet que si le
taux d'efficacité du vaccin a dépassé
90% comme on s'y attendait
mais le taux de possibles le taux de
positivité n'a pas beaucoup baissé et
cela est dû en partie aux ultra
orthodoxes et aux personnes qui ont
voyagé au royaume uni ou en afrique du
sud et qui ont ramené avec eux ces
mutants ces mutations du virus c'est
pour cela que les aéroports ont été
fermés et devraient rester fermés pour
encore deux semaines
je souhaite également mentionné les
ultra orthodoxes il y a eu deux
funérailles récemment et il ya eu
d'importantes réunions qui ont causé
beaucoup de colère une personne sur
trois testée positive à la coved sont
des ultra orthodoxes et benjamin
netanyahu a été plutôt lent a forcé le
confinement dans les communautés de
fortes doses car il a besoin d'eux pour
les élections qui arrivent en mars
quelques bien sûr comme dans tous les
pays il y à des politiques derrière tout
cela mais en tout cas le pignon sur le
terrain c'est que les ultra orthodoxes
le jouent pas leur rôle
le sont pas aussi prudents qu'ils ne
devraient l'être et il souhaite que le
gouvernement soit plus stricte envers
les communautés religieuses ultra
orthodoxes qui ne respectent pas le
confinement ne porte pas le masque ne
respectent pas les gestes barrière
justement pas là le parlement israélien
qui s'est prononcé en faveur d'une
augmentation des amendes contre les
contrevenants aux restrictions
sanitaires c'est la bonne méthode y
compris chez ses ultra orthodoxes qui on
l'aura compris respectivement la règle
enfin moi c'est la bonne décision les
amendes ont doublé la situation est
effectivement que certains ignorent les
règles
les aéroports sont fermés certains
disent que c'est une bonne chose
d'autres disent que ce n'est pas
nécessaire et c'est trop tardif mais
voici un exemple
de gens qui ignorent les règles ils
reviennent en israël et ne s'isole pas
pendant deux semaines à domicile par
exemple une sorte de chez eux en
laissant leurs téléphones chez eux donc
les autorités pensent qu'ils sont à
domicile alors qu'ils se déplacent dans
le pays
c'est un secret de polichinelle les
autorités savent que certaines personnes
ne respectent pas ces règles d'isolement
à domicile et j'ai également mentionner
ces variants venus du royaume uni où
l'afrique du sud ou du brésil la
fermeture des aéroports c'est une façon
pour traiter le problème
augmenter les amendes c'est un autre est
une autre solution mais la communauté
ultra orthodoxe est extrêmement pauvre
donc on lève des amendes encore plus
forte contre une population qu'ils
pouvaient à peine se les permettre
auparavant donc est-ce que cela va
vraiment modifier les comportements des
ultra orthodoxes
on ne sait pas ce qu'il faudrait c'est
que c'est que les rabbins
ultra-orthodoxes agissent indique thaler
communauté qu'il faut respecter le
confinement et suivre les règles et la
plupart des rabbins ont refusé de faire
cela disant que les grands
rassemblements font partie de leur
culture et que les les membres de cette
communauté n'ont pas besoin de respecter
les confinement strict merci paul à
slayer journalistes pour arte
internationale d'avoir été en vue de
l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du coup d'envoi de
l'examen du projet de loi contre le
séparatisme aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
est destiné à renforcer l'arsenal contre
l'islamisme radical c'est un texte
d'équilibré selon gouvernement
l'opposition elle le fustigent et puis
nous évoquons le traité de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et le mercosur
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie
c'est à dire un état inefficace tout ça
a été financée essentiellement par de la
dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
à
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître sa paire mieux de
mieux partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
j'entendais pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
va aller il faut que leur qu'istres
groove la musique c'est la traduction la
plus poétique de la vie si vous mettez
pas la vie bat évidemment on s'embête il
faut sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez 21h30 heure
française coup d'envoi aujourd'hui des
débats sur le projet de loi séparatisme
à l'assemblée nationale pendant 15 jours
les députés vont se pencher sur ce texte
qui entend lutter contre l'islamisme
radical
au total 70 articles vont être examinés
plus de précisions tout de suite avec
david kelly faron direct du palais
bourbon
bonsoir david alors que peut-on retenir
de ces premiers débats et bien c'est
d'abord un échange houleux entre gérald
darmanin et jean luc mélenchon le
ministre de l'intérieur n'a pas rappelé
elle n'a pas hésité à défendre ce texte
fidèle à la république selon ses mots
alors c'est un beau texte de protection
des libertés
c'est un beau texte de la laïcité in any
la naïveté ni l'hystérie il est que
fidèle à la république pour que chacun
puisse vivre librement exprimé son culte
pouvoir le prier ou ne pas prier si bono
chante aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs
les députés
vous faites la loire et en toute
objectivité les 15 jours qui viendront
le gouvernement se montre a ouvert à
toute proposition
fidèle simplement à sa pensée que la
république doit rester tel qu'il est
fidèle à la condition du général de
gaulle fidèle à 1905
fidèle à l'histoire de france journée le
leader de la france insoumise lui a
campé sur ses positions et a pointé du
doigt une loi inutile durant son
discours jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
hésité également à pointer du doigt les
rires exacerbée du ministre de
l'intérieur durant elle son plaidoyer
écoutez vous faites une loi qui à nos
yeux est une loi inutile pour une part
d'entre elles puisqu'elles ne fait que
répéter ce qui existe déjà et pour le
reste dangereuse parce qu'elles menacent
les libertés mais surtout parce qu'elle
ouvre la porte à un déferlement que nous
ne connaissons que trop et que nous
jugeons néfastes profondément à l'unité
de la patrie qui compte cinq à six
millions
musulmans qui sont nos compatriotes nos
parents souvent nos alliés toujours à
l'issue de cet échange jean luc
mélenchon a déposé une motion de rejet
préalable au projet de loi contre les
séparatismes une motion rejetée par
l'assemblée
une première séance vous l'aurez compris
assez tendue et les 15 prochains jours
de débats seront sur les mêmes bases
puisque ce texte fait l'objet de près de
2000 650 amendements annoncés comme l'un
des derniers grands textes du
quinquennat macron l'objectif est de
lutter contre l'islamisme radical et le
repli et communautaire en renforçant les
principes républicains est fortement
décriée par l'opposition notamment à du
côté à des républicains ou donc pointent
du doigt de nombreux manquements elle
dans ce texte et damien abad va déposer
un contre-projet dès demain je vous
propose d'écouter et rient se tissent
députés les républicains la france est
menacée par un ennemi un ennemi qui
utilisent les armes mais un ennemi qui
utilisent les âmes qui les exploitent
aussi c'est l'islamisme c'est
l'islamisme politique qui chaque jour
conquiert des territoires et qui chaque
jour fait des ravages
donc face à la gravité de cette
situation il faut ériger des digues des
remparts contre la montée de ce fléau et
je ne trouve pas le courage je ne trouve
pas l'action je ne trouve pas les actes
dans ce projet de loi susceptible
d'enrayer d'endiguer de mettre un terme
à ce fléau
les vrais sujets ne sont pas abordés
celui du voile celui de l'immigration
celui de la radicalisation en prison je
prends ces trois ces trois sujets ces
trois exemples mais ils sont révélateurs
de l'absence d'ambition de l'absence de
courage de ce texte elle déjà déposé une
contre proposition de loi vendredi
mentionnant a notamment l'interdiction
du port du voile dans tous les espaces
publics le principal point d'achoppement
de ce projet de loi se porte sur la
petite l'article 21 qui a restreint à
l'instruction en famille elle a visé par
384 amendement un record sur l'ensemble
du texte
en tout cas elle ce projet de loi est
divisait les débats vont se poursuivre
une deuxième si on ce public s'est
ouverte à 21 à 21h ici à l'assemblée
nationale est dès demain les débats
recommenceront à cette fois ci à 15h
pour appel à soixante dix articles
doivent être examinés durant les quinze
prochains jours
merci david canif en direct depuis le
palais bourbon et les religions de leur
côté dénoncent une loi qui met les
cultes sous tutelle protestants juifs
catholiques et musulmans estiment
qu'elles modifient le texte de 1905 en
donnant un grand pouvoir de police
administrative de contrôle et de
répression au préfet sous couvert de
lutte contre l'islamisme la liberté de
culte est elle menacée on en parle tout
de suite avec michel dubost
administrateurs apportent apostolique
celle de lyon bonsoir michel dubost
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
ce soir quelle est votre réaction face
cette loi l'été comme le disent beaucoup
des représentants des religions elle
était finalement inutile soit l'on vous
également je ne suis d'abord pas tout
elle plus administrateur apostolique de
lyon depuis quelques jours donc je suis
maintenant en retraite
alors pour répondre à votre question
pour répondre à votre question je pense
que cette loi elle est surtout
symbolique et que on va se battre vous
contre ce symbole mais on voulait
visiblement le président de la
république poulets symboliquement
signifier l'attachement de la france à
la laïcité et à une certaine forme de
laïcité
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on peut se
dire que en la lisant est telle qu'elle
est pour le moment avant les amendements
eh bien elle nous inquiète nous croyants
en général parce que la loi de 1905
était une loi libérale qui donnait qui
ouvrait des droits tandis que celle ci
elle ferme des droits si vous voulez en
particulier elle donne au préfet un
pouvoir assez considérable de dire neuro
ça ne correspond qu'à la république donc
on ferme
donc il ya là quelque chose d'essentiel
nous liberté de pensée doivent être
respectées par tous
je ne dis pas simplement religieuse mais
je dis que la liberté de pensée la
liberté de s'exprimer la liberté de se
rassembler ces salles qu on se rassemble
pour faire quelque chose ensemble
et bien ça c'est les oies là doit être
très bon préserver à toute force parce
que c'est le coeur de notre république
le coeur de notre état le cas de notre
laïcité et si on ne respecte pas ses
droits en les contrôlant trou eh bien on
n'est plus tout à fait jeune république
c'est certainement pas ce que veut le
faire le gouvernement mais quand on lit
on peut s'apercevoir de ça alors
justement michel dubost en croit cette
loi est-elle contraignant
pour toutes les religions comme vous
semblez dire bien elle pose un certain
nombre de deux demandes qui sont
nouvelles
en particulier elle donne au préfet un
rôle très important puisque tous les
cinq ans on doit j'allais dire
redemander la possibilité de continuer
et je le préfet a de sa propre autorité
le droit de fermer un lieu de culte
alors qu'en principe c'est la justice
qui doit le dire et puis on voit bien
que le contrat d'engagement républicain
demandé aux associations peu tel qu'il
est être très très extraordinaire et pas
très contraignant mais quand on le
regarde de près on peut se dire qu'on
peut se servir de ça de manière très
très contraignante pour la liberté
dire que par exemple quand on demande
plus ou moins de respecter l'ordre
public
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça peut être
interprété de manière très très négative
et voyez quand on lit cette loi on a
l'impression que la république se méfie
du religieux
or c'est une vieille tendance en france
on a opposé la raison qui était de la
liberté moi j'ai appris à l'école laïque
à un honneur et gloire à l'école laïque
où nous avons appris à penser librement
moi je prétends que je pense toujours
librement même si je suis chrétien et
donc j'ai à dire que la république
française à une méfiance vis-à-vis dès
religions
hélas cette méfiance s'exprime et c'est
contre quoi nous sommes alors la france
insoumise
elle nous dit c'est un texte en fait qui
stigmatise les musulmans et c'est vrai
que ce texte le ministre ne s'en cache
pas est une façon de lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
ça veut dire tout de même que vous les
catholiques vous vous sentez quand même
concerné par par cette loi lvo atteint
aussi et
elle stigmatise les musulmans selon vous
cette taille est à l'évidence fait pour
les musulmans devraient je me permets de
dire que probablement pour lutter contre
le fanatisme et puis dès le radicalisme
il faudrait peut-être mettre au fond
l'étude des religions en classe nous
sommes le seul pays occidental qui ne
qui refuse de s'occuper de religion du
coup si on ne parle pas de la religion
en classe et si on est pas on n'exerce
pas un peu de connaissances et d'esprit
critique et bien dieu se balade dans la
rue et et il est récupéré par n'importe
qui donc en gros c'était contre les
musulmans mais par définition et c'est
normal l'état le gouvernement veut
présenter quelque chose qui a l'air de
s'adresser à toutes les religions
et c'est là que ça peut être interprété
de manière négative jeu c'était évident
que il y a une possibilité de
stigmatisation des religions qui sont
requis dans cette loi même si
honnêtement elle est plus symbolique que
réelle
aujourd'hui clairement vous avez pu
exprimer en tout cas des catholiques
votre parole auprès du gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'on vous a répondu puisque
cette loi ne semble pas faire
l'unanimité
robert select est toujours la même chose
il ya toujours des zones et des
auditions notre président président de
la conférence épiscopale a été entendu
parler le relais des auteurs de cette
loi qui ne l'ont pas à bord apparemment
reçu le mieux possible mais enfin qui
ont su correctement et on a fait état de
nos préoccupations est le monde dit
qu'on écoute nos préoccupations et puis
le tabou de la vie politique continue il
faut bien reconnaître que rang il est
normal que ce soit le parlement qui
décide mais il
il est normal aussi que nous disions
notre avis ah bon merci en tout cas
michel dubost ancien administrateur
apostolique du diocèse de lyon merci à
vous
les échanges doivent poser les
fondements d'une ambitieuse loi de
programmation de sécurité intérieure à
l'horizon 2022 c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
premier ministre ce matin lors du
lancement du bureau de la sécurité une
concertation nationale censée rétablir
la confiance entre les français et la
police jean castex a insisté sur le
travail particulièrement difficiles des
policiers et gendarmes
il appelle à valoriser le métier je veux
vous dire ma conviction profonde
je l'ait déjà exprimé à plusieurs
reprises que l'immense majorité des
forces de sécurité intérieure effectue
chaque jour un travail particulièrement
difficiles dans le respect le plus
strict des règles d'engagement et de
comportement il est indispensable que
personne ne puisse faire pression sur
ses agents et leurs familles en les
menaçant ou aller désignant à la
vindicte
comment assurer la sécurité du citoyen
si nos propres forces ne sont pas en
sécurité jusque et y compris dans leur
vie privée
dans une démocratie la vie privée doit
être sanctuarisé pour nos forces de
l'ordre il faut redoubler de vigilance
débats du bureau de la sécurité doivent
durer quatre mois une concertation
voulue par emmanuel macron les syndicats
de police se montre méfiant mais ds qui
est fier avec antoine logié réformer
tout la police française en quatre mois
des changes
voici les objectifs ambitieux du beauvau
de la sécurité avec d'abord la question
de la loi loppsi loi de programmation
budgétaire et les conditions d'exercice
des policiers au coeur du débat
puis en toile de fond cette question
cruciale celle des violences policières
depuis les nombreux blessés dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes et de
nouveau au premier plan avec la sphère
michel est clair ce producteur de
musique tabassé par des policiers fin
novembre des violences dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises lors des
mobilisations sociales qui se sont
multipliées depuis le début du mandat d'
emmanuel macron une contestation qui
s'est récemment accentué à l'occasion
des manifestations contre le projet de
loi sécurité globale et son article 24
censée protéger les forces de
ordre en contrôlant la diffusion
malveillantes d'image des policiers
pourtant les liens police population ne
sont pas l'objectif prioritaire et ne
feront l'objet que d'une seule table
ronde sur quatre mois de travaux le
dialogue s'annonce difficile entre les
forces de l'ordre et le chef de l'état
ces derniers ont vivement critiqué les
manoeuvres des manuels macron on n'a pas
besoin d'un énième séminaire on sort
tout juste d'un livre blanc sur la
sécurité et on veut nous refaire le coup
le président a eu quelques paroles
malheureuses il se dit je vais faire ça
et acheter la paix sociale
mais c'est une enfumades politique des
policiers qui ont eux-mêmes manifesté à
plusieurs reprises en 2020 avec des
rassemblements symboliques notamment sur
les champs elysées
le dernier en date remonte à décembre
2020 une mobilisation suite à une
interview du président sur le média brut
dans laquelle des membres des forces de
l'ordre se sont sentis abandonnés au
mois de juin
certains d'entre eux se sentait déjà
lâché par l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner la
formation des policiers
régulièrement pointée du doigt par les
experts et une partie de l'opinion
publique en novembre 2020
gérald darmanin reconnaissait lui même
des carences dans le domaine il y à une
erreur fondamentale que nous avons
commises au ministère de l'intérieur
c'est le peu de formation que nous
offrons à nos policiers raccourcir la
formation initiale c'est à dire quand on
embauche un policier n'était pas une
bonne mesure
d'après le ministre de l'intérieur sept
ou huit propositions très fortes
devraient aboutir à l'issue des
discussions de ce beau mot de la
sécurité des idées qui seront ensuite
soumises à emmanuel macron pour tenter
de pacifier les rapports entre les
forces de l'ordre et la population comme
annoncé dans le programme et à travers
un tweet de gérald darmanin les tables
rondes seront diffusés en direct sur
internet
une manière pour le gouvernement
d'affirmer une volonté de transparence
emmanuel macron avaient refusé l'accord
de libre échange entre les pays
d'amérique du sud du mercosur et l'union
européenne d ou 2019
mais mediapart a dévoilé que sous
pression l'union européenne le
gouvernement travailler sur des clauses
pour la grée les explications de katia
technique on le pensait enterré voilà
qu'il refait surface l'accord trail
critique et de libre échange avec le
mercosur il porte sur les relations
commerciales entre l'union européenne et
les pays du cône sud argentine brésil
uruguay et paraguay
il autoriserait ces derniers à exporter
notamment 99 milles tonnes de viande
bovine 180 mille tonnes de volailles en
europe avec des droits de douane réduits
ou nuls
quand il est vrai qu'on en manque en
france cet accord élaboré depuis plus de
vingt ans et qui n'a pas encore été
ratifiée porterait un coup fatal à nos
éleveurs mais il provoquerait aussi une
forte accélération de la déforestation
dans les pays d'amérique du sud pour
nourrir le bétail
la forêt amazonienne a déjà perdu 8 % de
sa surface en 18 ans en majeure partie à
cause de l'élevage
autre sujet d'inquiétude le fait que la
viande de ces pays ne soient pas
soumises aux mêmes normes sociales
sanitaires et environnementales que
celle produite en europe en 2019 les
protestations tribune manifestation
avait foisonner pour dénoncer cette
concurrence déloyale en ou 2019 alors
que l'amazone y brûler emmanuel macron
avait durci le ton envers le président
brésilien jaillir ball sonar où il avait
alors refusé de signer les accords oui
mais avec la doctrine du en même temps
un refus c'est aussi une autorisation et
mediapart vient de découvrir un document
du ministère du commerce extérieur
examinant des pistes pour établir le
mercosur il liste des garanties à
obtenir des pays du sud
concernant l'environnement et les normes
l'europe estime qu'elle a à gagner à
exporter des voitures tandis que les
pays de la corne ou vendent des produits
agricoles ainsi la france fait face à la
pression de l'union européenne la
présidence portugaise du conseil de
l'union insistant pour que cet accord
soit ratifié de nombreux députés
européens et personnalités politiques
sont scandalisés la france a refusé de
signer disait la ministre
aujourd'hui les masques tombent d'après
médiapart le gouvernement planche pour
lever son veto sur l'accord
macron s'accommode donc d'un accord avec
bolton arrow qui met le feu à la masoni
eva contre nos valeurs
après avoir autorisé la commission de
bruxelles a signé le traité mercosur
permettant l'importation de boeuf aux
hormones puis avoir fait semblant de s'y
opposer
emmanuel macron se prépare finalement à
libéraliser les importations de viande
qui vont tuer nos éleveurs franck
riester ministre délégué au commerce
extérieur réagi à la découverte de
médiapart
non notre position est très claire le
gouvernement ne soutient pas le projet
d'accord eux mais reconnurent en l'état
tout est dans le en l'état mais en même
temps si l'on ajoute quelques clauses
non contraignante ça peut passer
car le ministre avoue bien mené un
travail en concertation avec les acteurs
concernés en france et dans l'union
européenne
mais est il réaliste d'espérer négocier
de telles clauses
écoutons l'avis de bruno dufayet
président de la fédération nationale
bovine et il ya aussi toute la
compatibilité de ce discours avec le
droit du commerce et des droits de l'
omc
il ya quand vous voyez qu'en france on a
mis un article dans le cadre de la loi
et il ya un article l'article 44 qui
normalement interdit la
commercialisation de produits ne
respectant pas nos normes
la france n'arrive même pas à mettre en
application sur son territoire cet
article là et on voudrait nous expliquer
qu'on pourrait demain arrivé à imposer
des clauses dans un accord dans un
accord de libre échange entre l'europe
et le mercosur donc là aussi on sait que
voilà c'est de l'enfumage c'est pas
possible
quel est l'intérêt d'aller nous mettre
en concurrence avec ces pays là une
concurrence est complètement déloyale on
n'arriverait pas résisté face à 7 face à
cette arrivée de massive de de viande
venant de partout sur la planète qui est
donc voilà là aussi quelle est la
logique pris en tenaille entre les
agriculteurs les ong environnementales
les protecteurs de la souveraineté
alimentaire d'une part et les pays
membres d'autre part emmanuel macron
aura-t-il le courage de continuer à
poser son veto contre le mercosur
rien n'est moins sûr et pour en parler
nous sommes avec nicolas giraud porte
parole de la confédération paysanne
bonsoir nicolet
merci d'être avec nous la france qui
refusera donc de s'engager dans un
accord qui en l'état contribue à la
déforestation et au réchauffement
climatique mais la pression de l'europe
est trop forte c'est ça mais ça y
ressemble en tout cas ça y ressemble
c'est à dire que on avait bien entendu
emmanuel macron le le 14 décembre devant
la conscience citoyenne pour le climat
dire que le mercosur
il ne passerait pas il ne signerait pas
ils viendraient ils viendraient de
combattre au niveau européen et on est
complètement la dent dans l'ue en même
temps c'est à dire que on n'en veut pas
mais en même temps on continue à
négocier on négocie des déclarations
annexes qui semble-t-il amènerait
quelques avancées sur le climat sur les
normes sanitaires etc
sauf que on sait qu'à chaque fois les
déclarations annexes à ce genre
d'accords sont totalement dévoyé et très
peu appliquée est difficilement
applicable à chaque fois donc on est on
va en nounou nous on est très très mal à
l'aise par rapport à ce qui est en train
de se jouer parce que on en train
d'accepter une fois de plus de mettre en
concurrence le mans de paysans français
et européen avec le reste du monde et se
dire que ben voilà 6e on peut continuer
à exporter nos voitures et nos services
pourquoi pas mettre les paysans français
et européen en concurrence avec ceux
avec ceux d'amérique du sud avant travie
paris cherche t'il vraiment à renégocier
ou va-t-il ratifié le traité en l'état
dans le fond quel est votre plus grande
inquiétude sur quoi vous ne céderez pas
mais nous toute façon on cédera pas sur
le fait de signer ce genre d'accord à la
confédération paysanne on s'est toujours
opposé au préalable déjà aux accords de
l'om c'est comme il était posée puis aux
accords de libre échange bilatéraux
comme ils sont rares et signé su avec le
canada le ceta ce avec le mercosur qui
sont en train d'être discuté avec la
nouvelle zélande ce avec l'afrique de
l'ouest
des accords qui sont désastreux pour les
paysanne les paysans de france est
d'aider et des pays avec qui on signe
également pour l' enjeu de souveraineté
alimentaire sur différents continents
parce que on est toujours en train de le
concurrencer et de tirer vers le bas les
productions c'est à celui qui s'assoira
le lieu sur ces normes sociales
environnementales sanitaires qui
remportera ces marchés et cette course
aux prix bas et donc c'est complète pour
des fastes à tout à l'alimentation à la
relocalisation au climat et à
l'installation paisible île en nombreux
donc nous on s'oppose j'allais dire on
reste sourd non seulement en l'état et
dans sa globalité on s'oppose aussi que
de facto on continue à réouvrir les
négociations en disant que le bas si on
peut par le passé par la porte grande
ouverte on va passer par la fenêtre en
catimini nous jaillir de l'un ou l'autre
on est opposé à ce genre d'acte
clairement nicolas giraud quelles
seraient les conséquences pour vous
paysan français
les conséquences les clés conséquence
elles seraient elles seraient assez
dramatique notamment pour l'élevage on
cible beaucoup l'élevage de viande
bovine
on parle aussi de la volaille ou y
aurait des des importations qui seraient
massives sur sur les a niés et sur les
années qui suivraient cet accord là
selon une étude de la commission
européenne donc c'est pas une étude de
la confédération paysanne ou ou de ou
d'organisations opposé à l'accord selon
une étude de la commission européenne
d'ici à 2030 les les importations de
boeuf et de volaille
elle augmenterait sur le continent
européen entre 20 et 30% en boeufs et en
voilà est à peu près sûr sur ces volumes
là et ces augmentations elles seraient
dues pour 44%
sur le boeuf au mercosur et pour 37% sur
les volailles au mercosur
ça veut dire que on aurait des
augmentations d'importation absolument
dramatique absolument massive sur des
secteurs qui sont déjà en grande
difficulté sur des secteurs où on
n'arrive pas à révéler les paysans où on
n'arrive pas à en engager la transition
des modèles agricoles pour les rendre
plus vertueux écologiquement plus
vertueux climatiquement est sur des
modèles où on nous le monde également de
travailler à la relocalisation dire que
l'on voit pendant que cette crise
sanitaire en train de vivre la crise qu
vide que l'enjeu de la relocalisation
est quelque chose de majeur qui est
question les lèvres de la plupart de nos
politiques
mais quand on nous met en face de cette
orgie de relocalisation les accords de
libre échange et la concurrence avec des
volumes à prix bas qui arriverait c'est
absolument impossible à la pensée à la
mettre en place et est elle à rendre
effective
donc c'est c'est absolument dramatique
c'est à dire que on est dans des choses
qui se pose complètement et on nous
demande des choses complètement
différentes
en même temps donc c'est impossible à
mettre en oeuvre et on se rend compte
que ce qui va se passer c'est que les
paysages les paysans français les
éleveurs et les éleveuses français vont
continuer à voir leurs revenus baisser
vont continuer à disparaître vous
continuez à pas réussir à renouveler
leur ferme
donc on va voir des fermes qui
s'agrandissent qui s'intensifie à des
territoires qui se spécialise qui se
sait réalise des combats dans un élevage
qui va disparaître petit à petit merci
beaucoup aux nicolas giraud porte parole
de la confédération paysanne
merci d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la
fin de cette émission prochain point
complet sur l'actualité ce sera demain à
8 heures heure française sur rt france
ait said en fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité
l'égalité des chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
gouvernance c'est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique
ça fait quand même beaucoup tout ça le
fond de moi la politique c'est la rumeur